c'est un test grandeur nature qui
pourrait bientôt arriver en france la
semaine de quatre jours la semaine de
quatre jours après l'espagne l'islande
ou encore le canada le royaume uni va
tester dès aujourd'hui la semaine de
quatre jours avec l'apport des mimes je
pense que nombre de sociétés se sont
rendu compte qu'il était possible de
travailler très différemment et cela
nous a encouragés à réfléchir à la
manière dont nous pouvons à notre
flexible moins de travail pour plus de
productivité c'est le pari de cette
expérience qui va concerner près de 3000
employés dans une soixantaine
d'entreprises britanniques ce test qui
aura lieu pendant six mois permettra de
déterminer si le quotidien du salarié
peut être améliorée sans ralentir pour
autant la productivité pour la majorité
des journées sont pas forcément plus
longue elles sont des fois peut-être un
tout petit peu plus difficile dans le
sens où matt plus de boulot sur les
jours où on est présent cette réduction
du temps de travail qui doit aussi
permettre d'attirer de nouveaux employés
alors après l'espagne et le royaume-uni
la france doit-elle passer à la semaine
de quatre jours travail
alors la france doit-elle passer à
quatre jours de travail alors vous
explique que vite fait le schéma
économique c'est que si on me libère les
gens un jour de plus ça permet de
dépenser son argent à venir marcher de
données de caubeyres d'ailleurs là on
reste à terrebonne l'économie mais bon
pour l'environnement mais c'est une très
mauvaise idée moi je ressens que depuis
le coc vide et cette période où tout le
monde un peu testé le [ __ ] travailler on
est dans une société où les gens ne
venaient plus aucune contrainte le plus
déplacé pour aller travailler ils
veulent plus travailler cinq jours sur
sept moi je suis désolée la réalité
d'une entreprise c'est qu'on a besoin de
gens sur le pont au moins cinq jours sur
sept qui assurent le le flux de travail
qui a et voilà je trouve ça désastreux
et quand on va à l'étranger je suis
désolé mais on a quand même la sensation
que les gens bougent beaucoup plus beau
et plus tard que tout est ouvert ça
aussi ça stimule l'économie a pas en
amérique par exemple bassil
les commerces sont ouverts le soir le
dimanche quand les stimule ça aussi
l'économie et le travail et ça me donne
aussi aux gens du pouvoir d'achat pour
dépenser la semaine de ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire trois jours de repos par
semaine ça bientôt on va plus rien faire
que travailler ça n'a aucun sens c'est
pas bon pour l'économie contrairement à
ce que je suis désolé si ça permet de
redistribuer de l'emploi en l'occurrence
qu'est ce que ça change que l'on
travaille quatre cinq six jours ça
change rien à ce que tu pètes est
important c'est de faire ce jour
récupéré va permettre d'embaucher des
gens qui sont au chômage depuis des
années et pourquoi pas d'avoir deux
semaines mais c'est la semaine des
quatre jours d'un côté les leur salaire
est semaine d'e3 bien sûr quand tu
passes de cinq jours à quatre jours donc
les gens
perso je vais travailler ça tu as moins
d'heures travaillées forcément
ça dépend il ya des pays il ya des pays
qui ont commencé à le tester c'est à
dire où aujourd'hui vous avez un
roulement des gens qu'il arrive les gens
qui travaillent trois jours et vous avez
des gens samedi dimanche aussi nicolas
il faut tester va parler de l'inflation
du croyant qu'il ya des gens qui vont
accepter de gagner 25 à avoir et que
l'inflation l'inflation l'inflation elle
est là pour l'instant on est le pays
aujourd'hui la france est aujourd'hui le
pays le mieux géré par rapport à la fin
de l'allemagne et l'espagne n'ont pas
hélas très gros dos de sa défense mais
alors comment on peut dire à des gens
vous allez travailler donc moins ok très
bien mais vous allez gagner gagner
moyens parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens ils
n'ont pas cette poignante et c'est donc
en valais on va vous enlever un jour de
travail auquel un jour de repos par
contre j'ai moins dosé y faire c'est pas
logique alors tu peux pas l'imposer donc
ça ne sera jamais imposé déjà
démarqué mais quand tu regarde
l'évolution du travail en france vous
avez bien vu qu'en 20 ans il ya une
évolution du travail qu'est ce qui se
passe aujourd hui classique vous avez
des gens qui essayent d'en dans les 35
heures vous avez des commerçants par
exemple qui essaye d'ouvrir un maximum
d'heures parmi les parmi les 35 heures
et qu'ils n'y arrivent pas donc il faut
bien qu'il ya un roulement un moment
donné ça pourrait être une logique que
tuer des gens qui travaille quatre jours
par semaine d'autres trois jours par
semaine et qui va être un jour
et quatre jours et pas de camion veut
pas dire qu'on travaille moi parce qu'on
peut faire plus d'heures pendant sept
jours et notamment dans l'hôtellerie par
exemple c'est un système qui est
largement publicité donc pour se reposer
trois jours avait retravaillé 12-13 qui
attend avec hâte et d'ailleurs oui mais
honnêtement dans l'hôtellerie c'est un
peu le cas déjà il travaille énormément
si ça améliore la productivité en
revanche baissé les salaires ça plaît
pas
qu'est ce qu'il ya mais s'améliore pas
la productivité il ya des soeurs qui a
des gens qui vont suivre les dossiers
sur quatre jours puis le cinquième jour
ils seront pas là ou alors les
entreprises what you may prend un cas
concret vous êtes dans un hôtel ok il ya
des gens qui ont passé quatre jours qui
vont bosser 12 heures donc ils ont payé
pareil ça libère un jour de plus pour
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de travail par
exemple d'accord mais d'accord non mais
peut-être pas pour l'hôtellerie miam d
entreprise dans laquelle la réalité
c'est qu'il ya des dossiers à suivre sur
une semaine par exemple sur un mois
complet et contre les personnes sont
presque pas la moitié du temps je suis
désolé c'est très compliqué pour les
pour l'entreprise et donc c'est du
chiffre d'affaires en moins de lait
c'est pas bon pour l'économie encore les
salariés parce que ça va rajouter de la
pression aussi patrick jacq à des
salariés des fois qu'ils ont beaucoup de
pression ça dépend du travail je veux
dire il ya beaucoup de pression quand on
doit tout réunir sur quatre jours parce
qu'il faut se dépêcher avant de repartir
en congé eh ben on augmente la pression
la fatigue le stress angoisse et après
ça devient compliqué image d'ascète et
testé en angleterre on va regarder ces
images on parle juste après donc cette
brasserie artisanale située au nord de
londres les neuf salariés produisent de
la bière 7 jours sur 7 mais à partir du
mois de juin ils ne travailleront plus
que quatre jours par semaine sans perte
de salaire
deux équipes alterneront pour permettre
un fonctionnement en continu une
soixantaine d'entreprises au royaume uni
vont tenter l'expérience de la semaine
de 4 jours pendant six mois le pays
connaît un taux de chômage au plus bas
depuis 50 ans mais aussi un taux record
d'emplois non pourvus 1,3 million des
essais similaires ont déjà eu lieu en
espagne aux etats-unis au canada en
islande l'expérience menée entre 2015 et
2019 a été si concluante aujourd'hui 90
% de la population active a réduit son
temps de travail
[Applaudissements]
les produits était le premier qui a mis
en place d'ailleurs la réduction du
temps de travail honnêtement il n'ya pas
semble pas y avoir beaucoup
d'inconvénients ya pas de chômage
d'accord mais ça serait peut-être mieux
d'augmenter les salaires qu'est ce que
vont faire les gens la moitié du temps
sans travailler s'ils ont besoin de
consommer en a à dire que gens n'ont
plus d'argent pour vip au voile à
atteindre leur dise de travailler plus
pour gagner un peu plus d'argent que de
rester chez eux de ne pas travailler et
voilà que ça envoie le ciel aussi que le
travail c'est mal c'est pas bien et
qu'on ne s'épanouit pas au travail je
suis désolé moi je l'attendais on est on
est sûr vous avez suivi quand même qu'il
ya un phénomène aujourd'hui dans le
monde qui s'appelle la grande démission
c'est hulk au vide et que tu es
aujourd'hui le postville justement vous
avez des gens aujourd'hui tu as envie
qu'ils ont qui sont rendus compte que
leur vie d'avant ne leur convenait pas
qu'ils ont envie mieux vivre dans sa vie
c'est peut-être aussi mieux vivre au
travail donc à un moment donné on voit
bien que les essais qui sont faits qui
sont plutôt concurrents moi je préfère
100 fois le plein emploi avec des gens
qui vont faire des roulements et
travailler pourquoi passer deux jours
sur 7 et si vous rêvez d'avoir des
boutiques comme aux états unis qui sont
ouverts 24 heures sur 24 pourquoi pas
mais c'est peut-être ça la solution il
faut l'anticiper il ya une génération
aujourd'hui qui est sur pied sur
l'emploi aujourd'hui qui ont vu leurs
parents qui ont eu 50 ans a demandé de
leur vie se faire virer comme des maires
de leur boîte aujourd'hui ce qu'ils
veulent c'est se protéger c'est une
génération qui osent dire non
accompagnons cette génération et si on
trouve des solutions
peut-être la solution n'est plus une
génération qui veut pas bosser c'est
s'inscrire à sony de sa génération sous
l'hypothèse étudia surtout protège les
sauces les femmes bossent on essaye de
se trouver un peu de temps pour
s'occuper de ses gongs co le monde a
changé ton écoute sort un peu vain dans
la rue mais je puisse être entrepris
joëlle chauvin côté lien avec guillaume
il le sait très bien ce tour l on
cherche les jarrets comptable et c'est
peut-être la solution rythmant opm
plaignant est mal pris comme base et non
j'ai roulé fait d'être l'attribution
juste d'accord couple mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que il faut aussi
que les gens travaillent aujourd'hui on
a l'impression alors lyon depuis
longtemps les gens c'est ça mais en
france on travaille pas suffisamment
quand par ailleurs on veut pas commencer
tôt oui on peut pas être mais c'est vrai
il faut le reconnaître comparé aux
autres pays je ne dis pas tout le monde
d'aujourd'hui en effet les volières
envoyé à auzon moment il peut plus
accepter ils veulent pas
écouter ce que je vais proposer à cyril
j'ai connu cette évolution pourrait et
la sélection d'équipé pascal thurre
déconne pas sa gêne il est je vous mets
un jour par semaine et je devais deux
jours
je m'adapterai parce que je crois qu'il
est là on ne sait pas s'adapter il faut
il faut y aller quel sumalla vous pensez
le monde
tu veux pas mélanger
des américains dont la protection
est bien c'est que nous on n'est jamais
dans la démagogie jamais jamais jamais
toujours équilibré j'ai un sujet pour
vous jamais un juste la condensation du
travail comment ça se passe d'abord
raisons non mais quand on concentre
comme ça les heures de travail comment
ça se passe pour le service à la
personne vous savez quand on doit être
plus ou moins détendu pour s'occuper des
gens ou même les infirmières et tout ça
si on condense les gens seront plus
fatigués du coup tout ce qui est
services à la personne ça peut devenir
compliqué aussi donc on peut pas faire
ça dans tous les sens
je n'ai pas compris la question